et si la bbc londres étaient la proie de
violents bombardements hier soir
bienvenue au ministère de l'information
département cinéma il semble croire que
vous êtes ce que nous recherchons pour
faire quoi
il faudra quelqu'un pour écrire
jacassements enfin pour les dialogues
je croyais que c'était un poster de ces
critères comme confier par tous les
saints garder ça pour vous trente
millions de personnes vont au cinéma
chaque semaine votre film montrera à nos
soeurs américaines que c'est une guerre
dans laquelle leur mari doivent
s'engager un certain nathan portr pas de
nom générique qui nous ne pouvons pas
vous payer autant qu'un la main notre
message doit être porté par un
personnage avec lequel ils pourront
s'identifier aux coups francs
la soixantaine fait quinze ans de plus
nous avons tous notre rôle à jouer dans
la défaite tickets repas ce rôle c'est
un rôle de cadavres ils meurent avant la
fin de l'acte iii juste une once
d'humour et ensuite le faisais moi ma
retraite avec plaisir non cilic
[Musique]
un tas d'hommes craignent que nous ne
retournions pas dans nos boîtes quand
cette guerre sera terminé bon travail
c'est excellent à nous deux nous allons
faire pleurer dans les chaumières
[Musique]
l'immeuble a été bombardé adam cole vous
croyez là dessous
désolé je n'écris plus jeunes
mais moi
nous n'avons ces opportunités que parce
que deux jeunes hommes sont partis
refusent et ne pas saisir ces
opportunités
ne serait ce pas laisser l'horreur de la
mort gagné soleil
les filles comme nous sont au service de
tous ces gens qui une guerre après
l'autre donnent leur fils et leur
petit-fils à la cause
[Musique]
si tout ceci devait s'arrêter même si
j'étais morte
ça me manquerait
blum tokyo
vous êtes allé voir notre film j
époustouflant
travail aussi
[Musique]
madame colle eux
où est elle coupez quelqu'un pourrait-il
dire monsieur milliards de l'extérieur
de dunkerque
[Musique]